[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week we're still at our
individual tables of adequate I don't
know you know if I've got adequate
lighting this week we think we're gonna
be here Hey we're both wearing gray
t-shirts is that better these are the
same dimly lit round table that's our
thing is is we're actually now in
contact with one another you know we
shot GMM together so we're no longer
social distancing from that from each
other because we basically have formed a
pod bringing our families and now it was
Stevie but here's the thing we thought
that we were going to be recording this
in the studio this week and we are going
to be shooting some gmm in the studio
this week but there's a bunch of
construction going on and people in and
out of the studio so in order to
minimize risk we're in here again
so we wheelied we're sorry or no we were
mistaken we're just wrong we were
mistaken we were wrong but you know what
we're gonna work we're going like this
yeah hopefully yes this one it but is my
birthday as we're recording this as with
everything else nothing counts
I mean you tweeted I appreciate you
acknowledging my birthday on Twitter I
will acknowledge that you acknowledge my
birthday right with you it was a mild
acknowledgment given the state of the
world I know you know it's like what
we've been through so many milestones
here at my home like multiple birthdays
multiple Mother's Day anniversaries you
know all types of stuff and it's just so
it's so hard to to work up the gumption
to like try to make it special because
it's like it's you just feel like I'm
just gonna wait I'll be it'll be special
again later you know and so I don't know
man it's and then you compound it's you
know we're not just we're not just
living in a world
that's a pandemic well you know we're
we're in crisis here in America you know
yeah well so we'll talk about that a
little bit because with what we're gonna
talk about when we get into the the main
part of the episode is we're gonna be
talking about getting older and not just
as two middle-aged men who are literally
older now but just the process of
growing up and we're gonna touch on some
different stages in life and we're using
your questions to explore that looking
forward to that but yeah so whether
you're in your teens your 20s 30s 40s
wherever you are let's you know we've
we've been through a lot of it and we
anticipate even more so we'll be
touching on all that stuff hopefully but
before we get into that yes we do want
to acknowledge what's going on in the
world I mean last week on air biscuits
we were talking about that I wanted to
because of just from my own personal
health to take a news break now wisely
you pointed out at the time that that
was really a decision that was rooted in
my own privilege of being able to just
check out and since then and we also we
talked about the the murder of George
Floyd briefly and how that we had just
learned about that yet accorded the
night before and I had a lot of anger
about that and just over the course of
the few days after that of course
protests broke out throughout the nation
they're continuing to go on right now
we've got curfews in place in Los
Angeles and things have really gotten
volatile out there and you know so we're
not gonna do I think the thing that a
lot of times white folks like to do
which is to be like hey let's get
together with other white folks and talk
about race I think that would be in one
sense that could be a little tone death
and I think that we have made an effort
to you know as a company but also as
individuals to say some things during
the
time but it's difficult you know one of
the things that I've learned just pretty
recently to be conscious about is just
the idea of not just doing the typical
thing where you kind of come in and say
your piece as if what you have to say is
so super important I mean I had a lot of
things on my mind and all my heart about
what was happening and it hit me that
the most strategic thing that I could do
is just talk about a little bit about
what I've been learning learning
especially from Black Voices who
actually understand the history of
what's going on in our country and
understand why what's happening right
now is happening and so instead of
trying to speak my mind necessarily what
I what I did is I wrote a letter to my
former self and tried to embody the way
that I used to think about these issues
you know which I was very sure was a
just in right and logical way of
thinking about them and I've since come
to the realization that a lot of those
thoughts were based in my privilege in
my in my whiteness which is contrary to
what a lot of people on the internet
will say is not a myth yeah and I'll
just jump in and say if you haven't read
the medium article that retro dime super
proud of fact that he put that down on
paper and or you can you can watch him
read it or listen to him read it on his
Instagram page so here I am finally
promoting your Instagram oh and also my
Twitter so you can shout me out on
Twitter and Instagram or Twitter I
decided I decided to read it because you
know I do
we talked about this last week as well I
mean every once in a while it's like
something gets me and I'd like I have to
say something and I'll write a medium
piece but you know it kind of just hit
me a lot of people don't read period and
a lot of people don't read me take the
time to just read an article and all
people don't want to read something from
you to a guy who's famous on YouTube
which I get that neither do i but i but
I thought that by taking the time to
read it I could maybe communicate how
personal it was and also get it out
there because again it's like I'm not
trying to speak
into the culture at large and I'm not
trying to be a voice that is telling
black people how they should be acting
and reacting to what's going on like
that's what a lot of white people that I
had that I know like to do but what I
wanted to do is I said the only thing
that I'm an authority on in this
situation is the way that I used to
think about this because I was there it
was me mm-hmm
and so I just want to talk about that
and so I'm not gonna rehash it here but
like link said I mean that's that's my
that's what I have to say about the
situation of course as a company we're
doing what we can to support the
movement to fight racial inequality and
injustice both you know by speaking into
it but also in giving but I think you're
not and instead of waiting until the end
of the episode to give a wreck I want to
get my wreck up front because I think
that rather than listen to us talk about
it I'd like you to listen to a very very
compelling black voice on these issues
in one of the books that was the most
eye-opening for me was stamped from the
beginning by Eber Mex kindy so this is a
first of all thankfully he has two
versions of this book because if you
just read Stan from the beginning it's a
it's a it's a long comprehensive book
it's a history book that covers the
history of racism against black people
starting even before America but then
the majority of the book talks about
just the history of racism in America
now if you're like us if you're our age
if you're from where we're from I think
we grew up kind of just thinking that
yeah of course there was racism against
black people I mean back in the day I
mean of course there were slavery and
then there was stuff before the civil
rights movement and but I mean now it's
kind of like I mean hey we had a black
president I mean everything's cool now
right and I think that that's a not
really understanding the depth
of racism in America and what that means
and what that has meant for black people
historically and what that means for
black people now so I heavily highly as
enthusiastically as possible recommend
reading or listening to stamp from the
beginning and if that 19 and a half hour
audible book is a little bit too much
for you to bite off he actually
collaborated with I think Jason Reynolds
is his name and did I think it's just
called stamped and it's basically the
teenage version of the content that's in
stamp from the beginning it kind of
changes the voice and speaks a little
bit in a less academic and more like to
speak into this generation and it's a
shorter read but it's just essentially
the same content so stamped by Ibrahim X
Kendy and okay I can get into target
yeah and I would just say again the
tendency and this has been my tendency
for my whole life my tendency is just as
events unfold in the world is to begin
forming opinions about those events and
then beginning to spout those opinions
off and talk to other people about those
opinions before listening and before
understanding the context and if you say
things like white privilege is a myth if
you say that there is no racist
oppression in America today a you're
flat wrong and the only way to learn
that you're wrong is to actually learn
about the history of racism in America
and you've got to educate yourself and
you and that doesn't mean the US history
class that you took in high school did
it because I took that same US history
class and they didn't talk about this
stuff they didn't talk about this stuff
to the degree and with the accuracy and
the stepping out of the traditional
colonialist white perspective in a way
that Ebru ms able to
so stamp from the beginning and also I
recommended for other books that are
kind of coming things from a different
angle but are all great in in the medium
article that you can I recommend all
those and the rest of them are shorter
if you want to try one of those I've
really had to come to grips with the
fact that being on the sidelines of this
issue is is perpetuating the problem you
know there's there are a lot of quotes
floating around that are mud say it much
more eloquently than that but for me you
know I've I haven't denied these
problems and I haven't you know I
haven't sought to actively undermine or
by any means you know but I feel like
I've been paralyzed because with a
combination of just not being educated
enough and not and just being and having
fear about deciding
to say or do things because you know
we're in this environment where if you
if you decide to say so you know my
instinct is not to take it take as
little amount of time as possible to
like understand something just so I can
then turn around and say where I stand
on it you know I'm very hesitant to take
stands on things because I just don't I
just don't have a lot of confidence when
it comes to that type of thing so
instead I just get intimidated and just
kind of move on to the next thing and
I'm troubled by it but I'm I'm kind of
frozen on the sidelines and I've really
come to come to grips with like that's I
don't want I don't want to stay there
you know but it's and so they're just
acknowledging the excuses in order to
work through them to say hey it
sometimes if you say something and you
say the wrong thing even if you're
trying to help then you're you make
people upset that you're trying to help
you know or if you put anything on the
internet that that that shares something
and that implies that you're taking
action or that you believe other people
should also take action it's it just
puts a target you know no matter what is
being said on the internet if you look
underneath it most likely there someone
is very much opposed to it you know yeah
and and you well and so I wig out trying
to anticipate what that is you know I
find it really interesting I find it
really interesting that one of the
accusations one of the accusations that
we've received this year we've become
more vocal right obviously we become
more vocal for a number of reasons we we
became more vocal once we kind of broke
the story of our deconversion
deconstruction and people have perceived
that were you know being more political
or talking about issues I think that
those things just happen to coincide in
one sense but
also coincided with 2020 which is a year
in which you're not getting political
you're kind of missing the point you're
not participating if you're not getting
political but I'll say that one of the
accusations that we receive sort of
multiple times is you guys are doing
this to like please your audience or let
me tell you everybody we've done nothing
but lose audience we've done nothing but
lose audience once what every time I
tweet something that is a little bit
controversial I lose followers so we're
not doing this to gain audience I want
as many people to stick around as
possible but that's not what we're doing
doing it but to speak to what you're
talking about with this hesitation to to
say something because you feel like
you're gonna say something wrong
first of all you are going to say
something wrong right when you speak
into these things you are going to get
it wrong and you don't mean that person
you're not singling me out I don't know
if there's anyone who makes a decision
to try to be a part of it is gonna get
it wrong and it's just part of the
process but it's also the way that we
learn how to do it and I think you'll be
surprised that if you just take a humble
posture and you take a posture that is
like I'm here to learn I'm here to
listen if I said that in the wrong way
or if I had an idea that was actually
based in some cloak racism that I didn't
even know if I had point that out to me
because I want to grow and I think
another aspect of that is the more that
I listen the more that I learn the
better way to engage right and this is
this is a really recent thing for us I
mean you know I think the way that I
have fought and felt about these issues
of racial injustice in America has been
a has been around for quite some time
but the way that I'm actually
interacting and engaging and and in sort
of understanding the depth of the depth
of the problem the persistence of the
problem that's something that's only
come that's not going to come by just
having
conversation with you you know saying me
and you can get together and talk and
pontificate and philosophize about
everything into the cows come home and
we're never gonna understand the
situation that's happening in black
America right the only way you're gonna
understand that is you have to read
listen to Black Voices and so if you're
speaking into this but you haven't read
a book like Stan from the beginning you
haven't listened to a talk or a video
you you're not following anybody on
Twitter who's speaking from that
perspective you don't have this you
don't have the facts you can't you know
you're coming into this with blinders on
and and it took me a long time to and
that's not just the case with this issue
that's the case with every issue right
it drives me crazy
the thing that drives me crazy is when I
if you find yourself in the wrong place
you know on Twitter or scrolling through
the comments you get bashed you get
pummeled by people who there's I can
discern no love or empathy in their
point of view it's one thing to disagree
or to make a counter point or to come
from a different place but to but that's
the one thing I do feel like I can
discern you know it's kind of sniff out
like is there any love any component of
love and what you're saying and I mean
that's why it's deeply disturbing to me
if you know if if I go to the
president's Twitter timeline you know I
just you know I it it deeply disturbs me
that I cannot just I cannot pick up just
a grain of of empathy and what he says
and I'm you know it's I know we don't
you know it's like well here I am
getting into you know best but hold on
but here's the thing that's not
political that's just human intuition
I'm honest we
view Lana seeing the fact that our
country is going through what it's going
through right now and we have a
president who we don't even want him to
speak about it because him speaking
about it makes it worse like that's
unprecedented that we have a president
who we do not actually want to say
anything because he will only inflame he
will only divide that's not a political
observation that's just a logical
observation about human behavior I don't
care what side of the spectrum you're on
you cannot deny that fact
he is not a leader he is a divider he's
making it worse it's the absolute last
thing that we need right now hopefully
it won't last much longer so let's let's
shift to a lighter topic of getting
older but first let's let's direct you
to the mythical store mythical calm has
all types of stuff do we just sell great
t-shirts since that seems to be what
we're the mood for today
well great t-shirts and all shapes and
sizes you got a v-neck it's kind of a
baby v this was your shirt and somehow I
got it and now it's my favorite shirt it
got too small for me this is my like
totally it I washed it too many times
it's very clean the the the baby v I was
looking in the mirror I was like
Christie don't like I mixed my neck like
so tall and my hair is getting bigger so
now I just look skinny
I don't know got a mess on somebody
where stuff when she was just right
I saw a side-by-side or an over-under of
pre quarantine rhettandlink on GMM and
today's yeah so that went up yes all
that recording this own leaks birthday
and somebody was like well Rhett looks a
little more homeless or whatever the
word they use was and link looks smaller
and skinnier but I looked at it and I
think it's just your hair's bigger and
you're also kind of like turned to the
side so I don't mean I don't think
you've lost that much weight in in just
a couple of months of you know
I lost some weight and then I gained it
back but I must I might have gained it
in a different place than my neck as
long as you keep it cut keep it moving
keep your shifting mythical calm that
was an ad that was an act okay let's get
into these questions will start with
Meredith Gordon is a bean fuzz on
Twitter do you believe in the existence
of a quarter life crisis I'm 37 so
obviously closer to having a midlife
crisis but since in quarantine I've been
thinking it might be possible to take
the quarantine quarter life crisis
intensive and get it done before 40 yeah
if you're 37 and you're having a quarter
life crisis that means that you expect
to be 148 years old if I'm doing the
math right well but she's saying I'm
closer to having a midlife crisis I
don't quarter life crisis I guess would
be like in your mid-20s but I did I do
not know about that I can relate to the
fact that like I mean being in
quarantine you're it's time for a lot of
reflection and so I've definitely found
myself asking what what is my life what
am i doing I mean I I would I wouldn't
call it a crisis so so de-emphasizing
the word crisis I do think I've had like
a midlife assessment period and it's in
it there's a lot of question marks
associated with that but it's you know
to turn in 42 and having time to think
about it more I just feel like okay
we've I've what's the rest of my life
gonna look like like I'm looking back at
everything we've done and by the way we
food and if you listen through a bunch
of these episodes you know we've lived a
bunch of life man I'm super grateful
like we've had we've had great lives
multiple we've had multiple narrator I
feel like we've we've lived multiple
lives we've had like different career
years and even in this current career
there's been like multiple iterations to
it and this year even before the
pandemic it was kind of a transition
year for us professionally because we
had come off a touring we had we'd been
ambitious about a number of things and
it was kind of like a regrouping phase
in order to then figure out where we
were going next and the things we were
gonna create next in addition to this
show in good mythical morning in terms
of building the company and on a lot of
fronts you know so it's I felt like I'm
in this midlife mindset
even before the quarantine and I'm I
don't know I mean can you relate to that
do you feel like you you're having a
midlife crisis I think that the
components of a midlife crisis and
that's why you're probably feeling it
and I'm feeling it too are you've been
working towards something and it doesn't
have to necessarily be your career it
could just be like you're just trying to
get you're trying to do life and and
there's a certain part of your life what
you're really trying hard to do life and
to focus and to move things to the next
level and then you start crossing over
into this place where you sort of
realize that oh what I was trying to
accomplish and kind of set up in my life
its kind of happened I have a house I
have a car I have kids I have a
relatively stable job and then you start
looking over the horizon in your life oh
so it's just this it's just this and
it's just more of this and then one day
I die and I think that that transitional
period like there's a point your life
where when you're in college or whatever
all you're thinking about is what's
ahead of you I got to figure this out I
I got to make the right decision about
what I'm
and then you may get like for us well
you know we went through the different
transitions to get to the point where
we're working together doing this stuff
and then constantly trying to just grind
and figure it out and build this
business and yeah there was so much
scrambling and and yeah for us I can be
I'm so grateful that we're at a place
where you know we're enjoying stability
even in the face of you know what's
going on economically relative stability
for us not not not total stability and
I'm still wigging out a lot but but but
the ability to have a midlife crisis is
a privilege right it it's a it means
that you've gotten to a point where
you're actually able to stop step
outside of your circumstances and be
like is this all there is is this a is
this it yeah you know I talked about
this book a long time ago you forced the
recommendation out of me the second
mountain right where it talks about you
know you work really hard to get out the
first mountain and if you either fall
off the first mountain or you get to the
top of it and at that point you realize
this can't be my Mountain and I think
that one of the things that's coinciding
with our midlife crisis if that's the I
will use that word you can use
assessment I'll say crisis is I think
there's no mystery in why this is the
year that we decided to tell our full
story about the Lost years there's
there's no mystery why I'm willing to
say that the things that I say on
Twitter and it's because I think that
this life has got to be bigger than me
just trying to be a successful person
and make it make it on YouTube or
whatever it is that we what we call what
we're trying to do right just like
actually I kind of need to think about
the mark that I'm legacy
yeah and it's I think that you just
naturally become so it's all about
everyone's gonna have a crisis the
question is just well what what is your
response to are you gonna buy a Ferrari
well I'm not you're just gonna become
you know what my Ferrari is gonna be
because I've been thinking I've been
talking to you about this I've started
looking at hashtag van life I don't I
don't know what planted this seed in my
mind but I'm like people are modifying
these vans like these Sprinter vans and
like once you click on one of those on
Instagram Instagram knows you want to
look at the inside of people's van so
I'm I'm like man these people are like
traveling around from state to state
sleeping and living in a fake their Park
in their van next to a mountain lake
opening the back doors of the van and
taking a picture from their bed to a
lake I saw this one clip I mean it was
somebody somebody had a they had like a
a GoPro stuck to their forehead and they
got out of their bed in their van they
they scooped up a coffee mug poured
coffee into it opened the door to the
van and it was a beautiful mountain lake
and then they walk out onto this little
stone pathway and then they just with
their coffee walk on the pathway and
just jump into the lake and I was like
that's gonna be the rest of my life I'm
gonna get one of these vans and I'm
talking about you talking to you about
it I'm talking to my kids about it
Lando's into it Kristi's like where's
the shower in this thing I'm like I
think you have to shower outside unless
the thing I don't want to I don't want
to be well first of all I was talking to
you I told you about this I was talking
to my friend's brother who had a van
that they were redoing and he was
creating a system that recycled three
gallons of water so you could take a
shower inside the van he was like trying
to yeah yeah yeah that's right but he's
just a dude and it's it's him and his
wife I think you planted the seed when
you told me that well but I really I
believe in this but I have I have one
hang-up for me personally and one
hang-up for you personally that I don't
think knows the showstopper necessarily
you know me I'm just a big man and
hashtag van life probably doesn't have a
lot of six-foot-seven aficionados as
long as your knees bend you'll be
alright but the second thing is is that
you have
it's a family of five so is this a I'm
thinking about sort of gone I'm thinking
about like making it a cut to the team
you know to make this van life thing
happen it's like well are you in or not
cuz everyone's not gonna make it the
idea of doing van life with my family is
not something that I'm into I mean I'll
do a vacation with them
I'll stay in a hotel I'm not I'm not
talking about no I'm not talking about
living in a van I'm talking about having
the ultra luxury of just being able to
get into the van every other month and
go on like you want me to go with you
sometimes yeah but isn't it just one bed
I'm not sure in a bed with you I'll put
another worst person in the world to
share a bed with I haven't shared a bed
with you I don't know I'm putting
another bed on top you can sleep up
there that pop-up party 2:10 I need it
but just for the sake of the fan fiction
people I do need to finish that sentence
though we used to go to like conferences
when we were in college and after
college
we're like forced college students would
stay in one hotel room and me and you
would share like a queen-size bed in a
hotel and you are not a good bed partner
because you move a whole lot better
before I'll say it again I sleep with
reckless abandon you wake up and your
face is right next to my face so I
definitely do not want to be a part of
that if that's part of hashtag van life
you wait until you see this van next
question Ruth asks know as Ruth doll 11
why does time seem to move exponentially
faster each year so like when you're a
kid everything goes so slowly when
you're a teenager when you're like the
more you want time that progress the
less it does and then the more you want
it to slow down the more it speeds up I
guess I guess that's that rings true for
me definitely rings true for me I think
it rings true for a lot of people and so
I looked up is there any science behind
this this is what an article in
Scientific American said our brain
encodes new experiences but not familiar
ones into memory and our retrospective
judgment of time is based on how many
new memories we create over a certain
period in other words the more new
memories we build on a weekend getaway
the longer that trip will seem in
hindsight in your vision Amin on which
Hammond Hammond is I guess the doctor
that there they're quoting has dubbed
the holiday paradox seems to present one
of the best clues as to why in
retrospect time seems to pass more
quickly the older we get from childhood
to early adulthood we have many fresh
experiences and learned countless new
skills as adults though our lives become
more routine and we experience fewer
unfamiliar events just like I said
you're like is this all there is
as a result our early years tend to be
relatively over-represented in our
autobiographical memory and on
reflection seem to have lasted longer so
it's not that in the moment like if you
sit an old person down and a young
person down for an hour it's actually
the probably the younger person who's
gonna feel like that hours taking longer
oh but actually that's consistent with
it but yeah it's not about that
it's really just the fact that you don't
have any points of reference you got to
have points of reference new weeks of
eerie memories it to me that that that's
the thing and I think I'm only this van
life thing because I'm so cooped up and
I'm I want to go to parks now I want to
get out of the house again and I want to
experience adventure and the
I mean maybe it's overblown because I'm
so cooped up and it'll it'll dissipate
over then over the rest of the year as
things continue to loosen up but fingers
crossed I don't know I'm not really
making predictions here but I do like
the idea of and we've talked about this
in the past like creating experiences
new experiences that enrich your life
and say you know I'm a creature of habit
I like to do I like getting things honed
and and perfected and then then
replicate it but it's not the that's not
that doesn't that doesn't make for a--
for the best life necessarily it
actually I mean in according to this the
more routine the faster your life is
gonna go the faster you're gonna piss it
away hmm
and not don't break up the routine not
even remember any of it
well it's funny because you know I'm not
a routine guy and I'm actually noticing
like one of the things I've done
consistently because we haven't had to
go into the office every day and so
we're not getting I'm getting up early
but I'm not having to get on the road at
the same time every day yeah is that I'm
meditating and I'm working out and then
I'm actually like able to walk probably
would like with Jesse at the end of the
day but it's getting tougher for me
because it feels like I go and I like
get up stretch meditate work out yes the
same only thing you must smoothie and
then I'm just like I got to eat
something different like it takes me
about three weeks I'm like I've had this
smoothie for three weeks and it's like I
start getting stir-crazy I'm like I
gotta have a oatmeal I got to do I got I
got to do something else to to mix it up
but the thing you're talking about this
this cooped up thing so I think I don't
know if I made this a wreck I should
have made it a wreck but I did I talk
about the book Underland did I talk yeah
you don't make that a wreck so when I
and I mean I was at the beginning of
quarantine I was doing this exercise
where I was sort of figuring out what my
values are and I don't mean that in like
a family values kind of way I was just
like what
what do I want my life to be kind of
represented by what I want to be present
in my life an adventure was one of the
things that I wanted to be present in my
life right I have a sense of adventure
you do too but when you get super busy
the opportunity or the the sort of
scheduling adventures can sometimes go
by the wayside and what I found is that
I'm just waiting for an opportunity for
a vacation
not anymore but before quarantine it was
like Oh Jessie let's go spend a weekend
in a hotel and what we'll do is on
Saturday we'll just lay by the pool and
I kind of discovered this like five or
six years ago and I was like this laying
next to a pool and reading on vacation
that's where it's at right but I started
realizing that we were doing things like
going to Cabo for a weekend and laying
next to the pool and of course it's like
beautiful and I love the company and
great food you know great drink whatever
starts to blur together you're also like
hold on but light right outside the
grounds of this hotel there's probably
like a cave that I could go into you
know like in the the thing I told Jessie
uh I was like when we travel from now on
I really want to make sure that we've
got a balance of adventure and
relaxation because you don't want to
just go and just run yourself ragged on
a vacation but to really think about the
opportunities for adventure that present
themselves in any given location or if
you know adventure in your own backyard
you know yeah you don't have to travel
to do it I'm not yet but I'm just saying
that I haven't even seen travel that's
primarily about adventure like you know
we went to France a few years ago for
that Film Festival and had it we
actually did sit what's the one thing
you remember about that trip what's the
one thing you tell people about this
cruder good almost dying on a scooter
right yeah yeah and it's like because we
made a choice for adventure that was the
right choice man that'll make you
that'll make your life short or long I
can't I don't I didn't understand your
science
and that you might die but it'll make it
make it your life longer grace Anna
tweeted I turned 17 in just a few weeks
and I couldn't be more ready for my
birthday and being one year closer to
adulthood but I felt like being so eager
for adulthood is almost wrong everyone I
talked to about this as adulthood is
awful how should I feel about my
impending adulthood adulthood is awful
I mean I'm 17 Lilly 17 it's like I mean
I had I understand you talk about being
cooped up there's like a certain freedom
of like wanted to get on with your own
life you know it's as a parent I what
her question makes me just think about
how how how I look at my family is
starting to think as Lilly seventeen
Lincoln's 15 Locke is 16 you know you
start to think about them just months
down the road of like leaving the house
they're gonna be on their own you know
it's definitely another part of Aging
for me I'm kind of co-op in for me as a
parent but I start to think about things
like when when my kids get out of the
house what what what are they gonna come
back to you know when they a van
apparently when the Asians are gonna
come back and there's gonna be a
foundation in a van on it you know am I
am i building a lifestyle for me and
Christy that is not dependent on kids
and it doesn't revolve around our kids
but also build build a future and start
to have dreams that my kids can enter
back into but it's not all about them
you know that's I that's then that's the
next phase for us right and I mean well
the best way to keep it about and so the
best way to keep it about not about them
is as soon as they leave to go to
college you turn their room into
something else it doesn't even matter
what it is it could be a gym it could
just be just where all the socks that
you debt you can't max
match our you know I'm saying just take
their bed their desk their posters get
rid of it all because you want to be
very clear about you will not live here
after you graduate college so don't get
any ideas unless you want to sleep on a
bunch of mismatched socks that's my plan
but I start to think about like am I
gonna live in this how is this the house
that Lincoln is gonna come back to with
his you know is this the house that they
bring their partners back to you're the
significant others hey mom and dad you
got a meat mmm
Derek I don't know I'm particularly
there's gonna be a garish involved Jesse
and I have we've kind of made this
decision that no is that that our
current house will not be that house we
were also like we'd like change and I
mean I'm surprised we haven't moved
already but I think that at this point
we're like we're committed to staying in
this location until Shepherd is that
which is like he's 11 so seven more
years until he goes to college so maybe
while they're in college we would be
like hey let's try something else
so and I don't know I haven't thought
about my that the child psychology
because I know kids like to come back to
something familiar so I don't know I
thought about that aspect of it even 7
more years in this house and I do start
to think about that too it's like I know
that there'll be a lot more memories in
this house and but there's also not a
there's not a lot of room for someone
for additional people to come back to
you know yeah but I do start to think
about that but to directly answer grace
Anna's question very quickly
you should feel incredible about your
impetus it's age 17 good listen the peak
of your life is right over the horizon I
mean listen you've got right now at age
17 that there's a bunch of things that
are about to coincide your level of
passion for things and your level of
freedom are about to combine in a
beautiful synergistic explosion okay and
you need to realize that don't don't
wish it away you you you have this
incredible opportunity to just not have
a whole lot of responsibility get a van
yes get a van we talking about a gap
year here is that what you're talking
about no well first of all gap years are
becoming very common because of Korn's
because of the coronavirus were
in a gap year right but no gap year yes
but I'm just talking about the fact that
you're gonna feel like college is a lot
but just let me tell you it's not it's
it's like don't mean I'm not saying
don't study I'm just saying that don't
fall for the lie that it's a lot it's
freedom it's for in and not everybody
goes to college but what I'm saying is
you're before them you got this gap
between being under your parents roof
and then being having a roof with other
people under it there's this window
that's the window of opportunity you
know I'm saying just see it for what it
is just see it for what it is enjoy it
newest ex suite there's no name
associated with this but that's the
handle it looks like Louis but with an
end what do you think is a turning point
for becoming an adult
I'm currently 18 but my life hasn't
changed that much these past years and I
can't see myself as an adult is it
getting a job a degree or is it just a
matter of age Kennedy at Kennedy kero
kero
kind of adds to this question at what
point your life did you feel like you
actually had a good handle on things I
just graduated college
and I will start my first big big girl
job soon and I'm very overwhelmed it's
like trying to figure out what win it
win are you an adult and when do you
feel like you have a handle on things I
mean I've said before that yeah
Christie's back there she's she's she's
malady never I think yeah that's exactly
right
I mean I think I've thought before I
felt like I've said before that I feel
like I'm an adult when I had
responsibility definitely having kids
made me feel like oh well I'm not the
kid because now I have one that must
make me the adult but it was something
that I kind of had to stop and derive
well yes to me I think the moment that
you become an adult is when you have the
realization that
no one has a handle on things ever like
it's the moment in which you which is
like all of a sudden you look around and
you're like oh they also don't know what
the hell they're doing this is great
they're all faking it they're all faking
that they've got it figured out that's
the moment you become an adult because
when you're a child you look up usually
because you're short and you see these
adults and they just they seem like I
mean they're moving in circle direction
britches yes they're like they're like
cranking up cars and like jogging and
bringing in food they're doing lots of
things that seem purposeful that make
you feel stable but then when you become
that person you're like I'm kind of just
doing what they did but hold on I don't
really know what I'm doing I feel
overwhelmed I don't have a handle on
things
that's the realization that's when you
become an adult
well Lisa at bleed blue bergen tweeted
one of these usernames crazy Lisa said I
think this quote would be a cool topic
point on getting older this is from
Alden owl and now Lynne never heard of
this guy have you know the day the child
realizes that all adults are imperfect
he becomes an adolescent the day he
forgives them he becomes an adult that's
an eloquent way of saying the same thing
we were saying that there's a level of
maturity associated with realizing that
no one is everyone's imperfect nobody's
got everything figured out no one makes
the right decision everybody's in need
of forgiveness and if you can give that
I I think that's a I think that's a good
measuring stick for for for adulthood
for maturity if you if you can forgive
people and probably forgive yourself too
and give you well and end to say hey
we're all just we're all just we're all
stumbling forward in time towards our
own demise
but we might as well live it up in the
meantime
another aspect of it I don't remember
exactly that the moment that this hit me
but there was a moment in which I found
myself living through a personal moment
in my life that coincided with the first
memory of my parents so that make sense
so when I started realizing like I
remember like seeing my parents be
parents there's a moment that I can
remember my parents doing parental
things and then there's a moment and
what did you see yourself doing the same
thing and that's when you can begin to
give to that pointer forgiveness you're
like damn it's hard to be a parent you
have sympathy for your own parents I
think you know even though it doesn't
help I tell my 16 year old this all the
time it's like I can't wait to you have
your own kids I mean that's cliche
pointless thing to say and I shouldn't
say it I say it in frustration but it's
also true because there will come a time
I'm hoping that there will be a phone
call or an email or at least a text
that's just like okay dad I get it you
know what I'm saying just and I think
that's the moment that's another way to
kind of gauge adulthood you don't have
to be a parent
it could be let me ask you staged your
life where you can relate to another
generation did you ever have that moment
with your parents what you were like you
know I get it it's funny today you know
I talked to my mom she she wished me a
happy birthday and she was like well I
want to know do you feel old as dirt and
I was like I laughed and she was like
when I turned 42 I remembered that you
told me man mom your old is dirt to do
you filled his dirt and she said she
remembered it you know she's been
waiting all he's waiting all these years
I don't remember saying that to her I'm
I'm sure it was a joke she basically
said it was a joke but dia I mean there
is an aspect of
aging that is you you talk to your
parents differently you know I mean was
there a point where you just the way
that you were what you're waiting for
locked it to text you and say you know I
get it
do you recall giving that to your
parents the way that that comes up for
me is you know do this all the time but
I'm not necessarily great at saying it
I'm pretty good at writing it and so in
in a number of cards over the years
whether it's Father's Day Mother's Day
birthday or whatever then again I'm not
super consistent in this but I've
definitely have specific memories of
sitting down and being like I'm going to
write how much I appreciate the you know
how my mom mothered me how my father
fathered me because I get it like I you
know understanding how meaningful it was
to have my dad president for all my
sporting events and stuff like that and
growing up and realizing damn that's
really hard to do like that took
intention and sacrifice so so
acknowledge so I'm saving that in cards
is what you've done yeah I mean I'm not
saying we haven't talked about it but
I'm saying that I in some fashion even
though I'm not the best communicator I
have communicated that to them I mean I
told her I remember one time when I was
in college
my dad had a camper and he took it a
Jordan Lake and me and my dad this was
like the first time ever that me and my
dad like did a camping trip like
sleepover thing where it was just just
the two of us and I remember we were
sitting out there at Jordan Lake and we
cracked open a bit we like shared a beer
well we each had our own beer and I just
remember that being a a milestone moment
I remember being nervous going I was
like I'm driving out here meeting my dad
you know I
yeah I never live with my dad accepting
like visitation situations but it was
really cool because like all of a sudden
we were just we were two guys doing
things that we would both do with our
friends
but we were doing it with each other and
we were having a conversation that we
would each have with a friend and I mean
that was a long time coming from me and
my dad you know because we never lived
together I there are elements of that
with all of my kids you know like I try
to speak to them I talk to them about
things and I talk to them in ways that
that I would talk to you sometimes it
depending on the subject matter right I
there are these parents who they never
stop baby talking their kids even when
they're adults like I I know of people
I'm not I'm not close to people but I've
observed people who would still talk
kind of like baby talk to their you know
their their daughter or son that's in
their twenties what yeah I'm thinking of
one person in particular that you you
but you don't know them well we need to
talk about this after because I don't
know if there's parents who never change
how they talk to their children and it's
that's just that's just not good it
seems like I never baby talked either of
my kids I just baby-talk the dog I
figured that she can take it
for entire life but but you know I look
forward to having an adult to adult
relationship with my kids that's why I
like to picture them once they leave
coming back and whether it's here or
somewhere else like I want to create an
environment where they want to be a part
of me and Kristi's lives well you know
the way to do this the way to do that is
really a beach house yes you you get you
either get a beach house if we're so you
know blessed to be able to afford one or
you rent a beach house and you taking
your adult children on vacation that's
how you keep them that's how you keep
them around because they are not gonna
be able to afford their own vacation
they're all going into a this world
that's gonna be all the robots they're
gonna have the jobs I mean they're gonna
want to go on vacation with you forever
yeah they're gonna want it they're gonna
want to like
take the hibernation pill and then only
wake up for hibernation to go vacation
with the REC with me and then just
hibernate again I and I think that what
we're gonna do and and what we will
still be making content on some level
maybe we will still be making this this
podcast I think that we need to commit
right now that we're going to be the
parents that they want to go on vacation
with you know I'm saying like you got to
think about it you got a you don't need
to be a survey or something I mean we
got to do like a kids focus group to be
like what makes going on vacation with
people miserable and make sure that
we're not the ones contributing to that
yeah whatever that is this commit to
that because just because somebody's got
the ability to pay for your vacation
doesn't make the vacation fine no okay
those are two completely different
things yeah all right Erica with a K
Erica very active mythical beast she's
got a I mean she her question was so
intense and so long that it took two
tweets looking back at myself and my 20s
and even early 30s and realizing that
many of my opinions and viewpoints were
still being formed by my parent I feel
like I didn't start forming independent
thoughts until later in life when do you
think you start truly having opinions
and views that wouldn't necessarily be
approved by your parents do you think
the need for approval from such major
influences parents slows down
progressive changes and societal issues
this is a big one to get into right here
at the let's just say yes she asked me
yeah that's my answer
yes hashtag ear biscuits let us know
what you think no we're gonna answer it
so you know when we talked about the
Lost years we kind of told our life
story and that we were raised in very
particulars for a way of thinking and we
don't think that way exactly anymore
in first of all that's a super common
thing not just today we that's been a
super common thing throughout the
history of the world especially you know
post-industrial revolution there's lots
of societal generational changes that
take place pretty quickly
and the older generations is like back
in my day we didn't think like this and
but so anyway and also most child
psychologists suggest that a child sees
a structure and in most kids need to
sort of rappel through that structure
even if they kind of come back to it
right and and Jesse now we're talking
about our personalities and we are both
rule-followers right I'm a three and on
the intagram I'm a performer but one of
the great ways to kind of exercise your
three Ness is to recognize the how to
succeed within a framework and then be
like oh I can do that
that's why I did well in school it did
well in sports and I was a good kid that
made my parents proud right he's really
good at that
Jesse's a 2 on the inning gram which is
not about achieving but it's more about
helping people do things and and
basically being there for people but in
the same way that she's a rule follower
so we got well into adulthood into our
30s still holding very tightly to
basically the things that we have been
taught and our parents have taught us
but we were also then talking about a
guy that we went to high school with I'm
not gonna name his name that was a
friend of ours who also like went to
church with us but then all of a sudden
you remember this prom one year junior
year or senior year he showed up in a
dress dressed but not just dressed as a
woman like he had on makeup and he had
done his hair and it almost was like so
well done that the first thing I thought
was who's the new girl right I remember
thinking that and then the second thing
I thought was that's so-and-so so-and-so
and it's time I was like oh that's a
funny joke like it I wasn't like oh I
can't believe he did that I remember
just thinking it like that was really
bold and like very funny like that's
that like he really pulled that off but
I didn't stop and think why did he do
that right now as we grew up a little
bit
I rely realized that oh he was making a
statement he checked out he rebelled
against the system that he saw in place
at the time he just did it in high
school and then he went out to college
and became became an adult who was
somebody that didn't hold to the same
worldview as his parents but it took me
to get to in my 30s before I began to
investigate the world view right and I'm
not saying that this isn't really a
truth non truth whether it's true or not
that's not what I'm we talked about that
a lot in the last year's this is more
about like the way that you think in the
way that you see the world have you ever
made it personal
right because you they just mu may
transfer the same exact worldview that
was handed to you by your parents and
make it personal and actually
passionately interact with it but
usually the process of actually wanting
to kind of take control and make it your
own one of two things happen you grab
hold of it and it slips out of your hand
you realize that's not for me or you
grab hold of it and you realize that it
fits your hands perfectly and you adopt
it but different personalities make that
decision at different times I kind of
got all the way through my 20s still in
a very performance oriented mindset
where it was about making my parents
proud and that's not everyone I think
Erica is saying that she's the same kind
of person my wife's the same kind of
person but a lot of people including the
guy we're talking about who went to high
school with you know what happened
earlier for him yeah I think from me too
it was I just I want to I want to if you
tell me the right way to do it and
enough people agree then it's just this
is just this is the safe secure path and
I'm gonna I can feel okay I can feel
confident and it's I didn't have this
sense of needing to discover myself or
express myself in a way that was counter
to anything that I was a that the plans
that I was adopting you know I just
I just want to I just want to feel okay
I just want to feel safe I don't want to
I don't want to feel like I'm I'm out
here on a limb trying to figure this out
but I just didn't have I didn't have
that drive I had another Drive had a
drive for security and so yeah it was I
think it it did take a long time for me
to start to figure out who who I was for
me and not for anybody else you know and
then if you you know we got married so
young that you transfer from okay this
is this is this is the family that I
grew up and this is a system that works
there too now this is the family that
I'm that I've formed and you know I got
to meet Chris ease expectation she's got
to meet my expectations it's like you
know you go from one to another at least
we did mm-hmm
yeah well into in the the second part of
the question about do you think this
slows down progressive changes in
societal issues I mean definitely it
does but and I'm not listen I didn't
study this I just this is total Rhett
pulling it out of his ass which is a
good bit of what I say but my theory on
this the way that I think about like a
societal progression right because I do
I mean I think one of the big changes in
worldview that happened like when I was
a evangelical Christian I saw the world
as getting progressively worse right and
because that's consistent with
eschatology you know the idea that
things are gonna slowly get
progressively worse and then Jesus is
gonna come back right now that I'm more
I don't believe that anymore and I'm
more progressive than my mindset I
actually think that the world is getting
better and I actually think if you read
Steven Pinker's latest book I think the
facts are
on the side of it actually even though
it seems more chaotic and you're getting
a lot more information that makes its
even right now with riots happening
throughout the throughout the nation you
may be all everything is going crazy
well in reality basically every marker
that you can measure society is getting
better over time right so I think the
facts are on the side of things are
progressing but what I've always said is
that stretching progression like you
know social progressive stuff is like
stretching the fabric of society right
and it eventually fills in and you
stretch it and I think that people only
have so much capacity for change it's
like you pull it you pull it too hard
and sometimes it rips and then you got
to stitch it and you got to keep pulling
I'm just I believe that you keep pushing
things in the right direction and to me
it's it's just a good segue to zoom out
and say yeah I I feel like with what's
going on right now we're at such a
pivotal moment in history and such a
it's such an important moment in time
that we can choose to be on the
sidelines be part of the problem would
be a part of the solutions be a part of
the the evolution the positive evolution
of society and I do have hope that as to
bring a full circle as we listen and as
we have open minds and open hearts that
it's a it's a privilege to have the
opportunity to be a part of of what's
happening now and it's it's scary and
there's no clear path forward on a
number of fronts you know what you think
about racial injustice what do you think
about the environment where you think
about this pandemic you can add things
to the list
but we're we're a part of it you know
and we can we can impact it and we can
we can do that stretching and I'd you
know I'm choosing to find hope in that
and to to find a way to be a part of it
and to to move forward and not just try
to escape or ignore or just get old yeah
well you know and I think that you were
talking about earlier the aspect of
feeling like you're standing on the
sidelines sometimes and I think
everybody probably has a tendency to
feel that way I the way that I've kind
of seen my role and this stretching of
societal fabric over the course of my
life is that first of all you know my
personality is one who is naturally
gonna grab onto the blanket
I'm gonna grab onto the fabric that's
the kind of way I live my life right and
I spent a good portion of my life
pulling on pulling on one side of that
fabric trying to keep it in place and I
feel like one of the things that I'm
doing in the second half of my life is
saying you know what I actually feel
like I was wrong
and I'm moving to the other side of the
blanket and I'm pulling on it and it's
that's kind of the way that I see the
two halves of my life and the way I've
kind of contributed to the this what you
know what Erika is kind of talking about
these bigger societal issues and so in
some ways I kind of feel like I'm making
up for things that's just I don't know
if that's right or wrong but that's
that's how I interact with it and I
don't think and I do think that there
was sort of this middle period where was
kind of like all right I kind of let me
do it I'm gonna let go of the blanket
I'm letting go of the fabric everybody's
pulling on I'm gonna just watch for a
little bit and then once I was like okay
I think I know which direction I want to
pull
I've just been pulling it harder yeah I
mean in the context of aging we've
talked about like being engaged I mean
you can you can let life pass you by as
they say you can let life happen to you
or you can happen to life you know I
think that's the thing that I want to I
want to be engaged I want to be
happening to life and not life just
happening to me life throws a lot at us
and there's the end but when you respond
yeah we we
we do have the ability to engage and I
think that that's again that's exciting
that's a place where there's hope in
that yeah well in the in the last thing
I'll say is I think that the biggest
difference with the way that I engage
about these things just you know and
specifically like the issue of racial
and justice right I think that I spent a
good portion of my life thinking about
what I had to protect personally right
like what were my rights in my interests
and how do I hold tightly to those and
how do I protect those and I think the
one of the biggest changes that has
taken place over the past decade is
trying to think a little bit less about
what I have and what my rights are and
think about people who have been
marginalized people have been denied
rights people have been denied
opportunity people who don't have the
same opportunity that I have and think
oh okay I kind of want to realign my
actions the way I give we have spent my
time and the things I say and who I vote
for to you know take those people into
account rather than just think about
what I have and what's mine and what I
can protect it and that may be an
oversimplification but it's been helpful
for me to see it that see it that way
and I think it it's a good sort of North
Star as Larry you think about yourself
or you think about others yeah because
you only got one life to live unless we
have more that I don't know about you
you won't know and if you do you
probably won't remember it unless you it
unless you adhere to a particular faith
system that recognizes that and then you
like do some sort of exploration of your
past lives but who's to say that you'll
be able to do that you might find your
felt itself in a worldview that denies
that and you'll miss out all the
opportunities of living your subsequent
lives
hashtag Gear biscuits if anything we've
said except for the very last part even
that I don't care has that even that has
given you something that you did you
want to weigh in on please do that let's
keep the conversation going and I'll
look forward to maybe not not being in
separate places for the next year
biscuit next week but we will speak at
the fingers crossed and thanks for your
questions as always you're contributing
to the conversation let's carry the
conversation on on the Internet to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]